I once thought of the same
now look at it
in yet another augmented terror attack
251 passengers aboard sistent Airlines
flight 451 for kids when an elephant
offenders are broke into the planes
cockpit and ruthlessly butchered into
play
details recovered from the black box
recorder suggest that the man may have
been suffering flashback to the organ
Siddhant that horrible day two years ago
and augmented people all over the world
flew into a psychotic killing spree
causing the greatest loss of life in
recent history
sometimes you just have to let go
and embrace what you've become not gonna
go all wonky on us now answer oh yeah
well if I do McCready
I'm guarantee you'll never see it coming
no reason to assume you would good
because you are the only augmented
operative on this team and I intend to
make good use of you
we got a sandstorm barreling down on us
and we can't afford to make mistakes
we're going after this man an arms
dealer named Shepherd he's ex bell tower
one of the Special Forces commanders who
disappeared during the incident and he's
come out of hiding it's not he's selling
weapons and military-grade augments to
terrorists this is a run sing the
undercover agent elude Shepard out of
his hole the best you see in the polls
got but three years he's worked hard to
get in tight at the gym an Iraqi
smuggling cartel that's infected the
eastern hemisphere like a plague last
week
now I'm still a sent a message to the
Djinn offering to sell them a shitload
of black-market merchandise dirt cheap
they told Singh to handle it by they're
not gonna like it when everybody stops
their party sings cover really that good
it is right now we need to keep it that
way
this is where the deals going down a
half-finished high-rise hotel that's
been abandoned ever since the incident
it's not a pretty picture inside let me
guess
most the laborers were augmented with
heavy duty industrial groups so when the
incident hit and they all went schizo
things got gruesome real fast and no one
except for some homeless junkies have
been inside the place ever since so
what's the plan director Singh's
meetings Shepard on the ground floor
inside the hotel's main atrium
he sent the ball can be Jin crew to the
penthouse levels to secure a vantage
point and what McCready's team to take
our positions overlooking the atrium and
make the arrest
Jensen you're going in solo from the
roof my objectives keep the Jin from
joining the party as far as we can tell
only one route connects the atrium to
the penthouse level a halfway decent
elevator shaft here I want you to block
access to it
fine just coming loose
do you plan on relying solely on your
opens for this one I'd recommend taking
a little hardware just to be sure
we've got a you see in that might be
easier to maintain his cover if he's not
the only one still breathing when this
is done
smart thinking yeah but if anything does
happen to him you will be telling his
wife after you get out of the hospital
of course
what about range there's lots of white
spaces and high ceilings in there but a
number of tight and constrained rooms
two don'ts a crapshoot
really
never once wanted to play the odds give
me something I can use up close you got
it
one last thing Jensen Singh said the
jinnee using some sort of portable Wi-Fi
device to boost communications he's got
a better chance of maintaining cover if
you disable keep an eye out for it but
already on the clock here you said
there's a storm moving in there is and
we got the intel on this mission at the
very last minute
so we're scrambling a little if it comes
to it
your number-one priority is keeping the
gin out of that atrium copy that you're
up first Jetson let's do this
cosmos action this is knife leader he
just drives and descendant angel
Jennsen we're moving through oh [ __ ]
what's wrong
the gin of got for you Jenny's up and
running gonna have to hack keypads she
enjoyed McCready
they have colors and shapes just
remember the red means bed [ __ ] you
anomaly detected
tres program initiated
access granted
whatevs I think
Natalia
fantastic
I live near there he ashamed
Jennsen Mac listen up Doppler shows that
sand storms moving in fast it's big and
it's gonna hit us hard god I hate the
[ __ ] desert confirm visual I can time
is not on our side copy that
solid copy
I got
and stop the signal system already
rising
last thing we need is the comes digging
down
Jennsen what's your 20 working my way
through the penthouses remember to keep
an eye out for the djinns communications
booster if you can disable it Roger that
any outdoor equipment
Miller had to say what the djinns
columns booster should make it harder
for them to listen aunty
Goodwin with luck sings cover will still
be intact when this is over Roger that
we're not a primary target now listen up
everyone
chance hacked into the djinns radio
signal checking the patch now we should
be hearing sing any second
rugger lay barren I get a venturi
reheard libidinous
in a hassle Ileana Mikasa read the
screen
solid copy good I'll repurchase once a
deal kicks off
that's not what I meant
I meant we should be in the atrium with
him not up here ah
Jensen we're inside the atrium taking
our positions on the terraces what's
your 20 still moving or hurry the [ __ ]
up
enemy helos inbound and miss sandstorms
getting close you get that comms booster
disabled perminov boosters right so
maybe the 10 man does have a heart after
all way to look out for your team
Creedy out
anomaly detected
trick access granted
this is Jensen that house access for
insecure gin junior prom
copy that about [ __ ] time enemy helo
sighted
all right strike force position and hold
position
strike two all set Jake three yeah
eyes up sake ease up guys
yeah no [ __ ] drone though watch your
[ __ ] mouth Holliday
both of you shut up five in position
everybody stay sharp
sings got eyes on Shepard touching you
in now targets in the AO remember sings
down there so watch your fire you got
ball sync executing a by with a
sandstorm on our ass I cannot take
credit for mother nature
mister you can call me Shepard and lose
the weapons
the orcs they're getting harder to come
by guns are still on the chopper show me
the cash quick and Shepard is dead
what by who what's going on down there
Miller this isn't the gin repeat it's
not her chin making a grab for the
chopper you got a shot down here we
can't let that chopper take off Jensen
hey guys we're gonna move sing Jensen I
can't reach him
Jennsen this said store might have just
bought us some time but you need to
disable that truck cover there
no choppers wasted repeat choppers